what we're going to do in this video is
get some more practice identifying when
to use u-substitution and picking and
appropriate you so let's say we have the
indefinite integral of natural log of X
to the to the 10th power all of that
over X DX does u substitution apply and
if so how would we make that
substitution
well the key for u substitution is to
see do I have some function and its
derivative and you might immediately
recognize that the derivative of natural
log of X is equal to 1 over X to make it
a little bit clearer I could write this
as the integral of natural log of X to
the 10th power times 1 over X DX now
it's clear we have some function natural
log of X being raised to the tenth power
but we also have its derivative right
over here 1 over X so we could make the
substitution we could say that U is
equal to the natural log of X and the
reason why I pick natural log of X is
because I see something I see its exact
derivative here or something close to
its derivative in this case it's its
exact derivative and so then I could say
D u DX D u DX is equal to 1 over X which
means that D U is equal to 1 over X DX
and so here you have it this right over
here is d u and then this right over
here is our u and so this nicely
simplifies to the integral of U to the
10th power u to the 10th power D U
and so you would evaluate what this is
find the antiderivative here and then
you would back substitute the natural
log of X for u and to actually evaluate
this indefinite integral let's do
another one
let's say that we have the integral of
let's do it let's do something let's do
something interesting here let's say the
integral of
and X DX does u-substitution
apply here and at first you say well I
just have a tangent of X where is its
derivative but one interesting thing to
do is well we could rewrite tangent in
terms of sine and cosine so we could
write this as the integral of sine of X
over cosine of X DX
and now you might say well where does
u-substitution apply here well there's a
couple of ways to think about it you
could say the derivative of sine of X is
cosine of X but you're now dividing by
the derivative as opposed to multiplying
by it but more interesting you could say
the derivative of cosine of X is
negative sine of X we don't have a
negative sine of X but we can do a
little bit of Engineering we can
multiply by negative one twice so we
could say the negative of the negative
sine of X and I stuck one of them you
could say negative ones outside of the
integral which comes straight from our
integration properties this is
equivalent I can put a negative on the
outside and negative on the inside so
that this is the derivative of cosine of
X and so now this is interesting in fact
let me rewrite this this is going to be
equal to negative the negative integral
of 1 over cosine of x times negative
sine of X DX now does it jump out at you
what are you might be well I have a
cosine of X in the denominator and I
have its derivative so what if I made
you equal to cosine of X U is equal to
cosine of X and then D u DX would be
equal to negative sine of X or I could
say that D U is equal to negative sine
of X DX and just like that I have my D u
here and this of course is my U and so
my whole thing has now simplified to
it's equal to the negative indefinite
integral of 1 over u 1 over u D U which
is a much easy
you're integral to evaluate and then
once you evaluate this you back
substitute cosine of X for you